So where did fencing come from?
An early form of fencing for sport can be traced back to ancient Egypt.
The fencing as we know it today derive from the European duel.
The design of swords evolved from a defense and hunting strategy...
...of cutting and slashing to thrusting...
...because it was far more deadly and effective.
The foil is the lightest of the three fencing weapons,...
...and it appeared around 17th century Europe...
...as a practice weapon for the small sword,...
...a fashionable weapon often used in a duel to settle disputes.
Around this time, fencing schools were established in Italy, Spain and France,...
...elevating the practice to a form of art and exercise.
Foil fencing rules are the most limiting.
You can only hit the torso and back and only with the tip of the foil blade.